[Music]
all you early risers day creatures new
lizards people of the sun
be careful out there sunburn cut off at
7 22 pm and toxic level drop-off is 805.
the big heat-up happened it created this
desperate need for augmented day workers
and human cloning was born
do you ever go out there look at the sun
with your own eyes
you just take your lithium x like
everybody else
what is it that you feel you have failed
with
you're on premium three when you're dead
you'll be eligible for a total upgrade
i wouldn't want to live without you okay
is that such a bad thought
you can tailor your insurance spouse so
that maybe they come back to you
just perfect there's nothing to do
baby it's already been done
calm down or it's gonna be very messy
why this is like i'm the only one that
feels this way
we're all connected are you afraid to
die
i don't feel any pain actually i i don't
feel anything at all
imagine yourself feeling better looking
better did you not think it was
dangerous
playing god like that
one person can set something in motion
and the rest of the world is never the
same again
[Music]
you